budapest hungary one of europe's hidden
jewels
a tourist hotspot known for its history
and beautiful architecture and its love
of water
but while most splash above the surface
below the city is a secret subterranean
world
hungary's capital is home to over 80
geothermal springs and dozens of bats
all heated by the earth's warmth deep
below the surface
as this naturally heated water flowed
beneath the city it carved out hundreds
of caves making the city home to the
largest collection of thermal caves in
the world
the crown jewel of this system is the
molnar janos cave discovered in the 19th
century by janos molnar who traced the
warm spring waters from the lake outside
to its source beneath the city
[Music]
divers first started to explore the cave
in the 1950s since then nearly four
miles of tunnels have been charted
in the pitch black of the cave miles of
rope have been laid for divers to follow
the correct route back to the exit
the water is naturally warm between 70
and 80 degrees fahrenheit
the rooms of the cave can range from
tiny to massive the largest is so large
it can hold 350 double-decker buses
and even in the pitch black life has
found a way
biologists have identified new species
that live only in these caves
much is still to be answered about this
place a reminder that even in the most
urban of areas you can still find some
of nature's greatest wonders
you